[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 3 juillet
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal de tv 78
l'essentiel de l'actualité locale et
régionale voici les titres de cette
édition
l'interview du colonel luis barras le
commandant de la gendarmerie des
yvelines va bientôt quitter ses
fonctions
il revient sur ses trois années passées
dans le département mais aussi sur la
mobilisation des gendarmes cet été
opération tranquillité vacances sécurité
routière les actions sont nombreuses
travailler toute une année scolaire sur
un projet scientifique l'objectif du
défi techno 150 classes du territoire
ils y ont participé la remise des prix
se tenait cette semaine à la commanderie
à locaux et puis petit tour du côté de
la fête des loges la célèbre foire vient
pour l'a350 septième fois en forêt de
saint germain en laye c'est jusqu'au 18
août
un événement pour les familles et les
amateurs de sensations fortes
mais avant de développer ces titres est
la mauvaise nouvelle pour les salariés
de conforama à vélizy villacoublay
le magasin est parmi les huit dans la
région et les 32 en france qui vont
fermer en 2020 la liste dont ne fait pas
partie le site de coignières à l'image
conforama détenus par le groupe africain
sud-africain stand off a confirmé le
lancement d'un vaste plan de
restructuration en tout ce sont neuf
mille neuf mille 1900 postes et qui sont
menacés de suppression
une passation à la direction régionale
des douanes de paris ouest ce matin à
joseph 20 à la pris officiellement la
direction du service en remplacement de
claire alarmant canitrot cérémonie
d'installation à saint-germain-en-laye
ce service rattaché au ministère de
l'action et des comptes publics à
plusieurs missions parmi lesquels lutter
contre les grands trafics et à protéger
protéger les citoyens et des territoires
des trafics illicites en 2018 par
exemple 13,7 tonnes de produits
stupéfiants ont été saisis joseph venzal
a sous sa direction 1200 personnes
réparties sur les départements des
yvelines de l'essonne des hauts de seine
et du val d'oise est les propos sont
recueillis par mélanie poké les un jeu
de ce territoire sont colossaux vous
avez le bureau des jeunes villiers qui
est le sixième bureau français en termes
de des doigts
nous avons des enjeux de compétitivité
des entreprises en leur permettant
d'accéder à un certain nombre de
facilitation en matière de sécurité il
ne vous aura pas échappé que la région
parisienne est plutôt bien desservi par
les trafics en tous genres
qu'il s'agisse des stupéfiants des
tabacs des contrefaçons
et encore une fois le cepd direction
régionale de paris ouest est idéalement
situé avec des trafics au sens légal du
terme on cote de marchandises qui nous
permettent d'appréhender un certain
nombre de choses autre passation celle
ci à la gendarmerie des yvelines le
colonel loïc barras s'en va après trois
ans passés à la tête du groupement au
micro de nicolas dendre il se confie sur
son bilan est présente aussi l'action
des gendarmes pendant l'été dans le
département yves hub steyn berger pour
les moyens techniques colonel loïc
barras bonjour bonjour c'est votre
dernier jour de commandement est ici au
groupement de gendarmerie nationale des
yvelines à versailles
quel bilan vous fait de vos trois années
d'exercice ici alors oui trois ans
qu'ils ont passés très vite donc on a
beaucoup travaillé avec mes équipes dans
le volet judiciaire où on a
mis en place des groupes d' enquête
lutte anti-cambriolage puisque c'est un
phénomène qui touche beaucoup les
yvelines je dirais également sur
l'accueil des victimes et les victimes
d'infractions pénales dans le domaine de
violences intrafamiliales où nous avons
créé une brigade de protection des
familles qui est maintenant à bois
d'arcy une fonction intervention où nous
avons également améliorer la
surveillance nocturne dans le mantois
avec le groupe orion et enfin le contact
qui est quelque chose de très important
pour les gendarmes avec la création
d'une brigade de contact brigade
territoriale de contact on va revenir
dessus parce que c'est l'un des piliers
de la période estivale pendant que tout
à fait les yvelinois sont en vacances
mais avant j'aimerais revenir sur
quelque chose que vous avez mis en place
dans les yvelines c'est la numérisation
des outils les gendarmes voyez tout à
fait alors maintenant les gens à me
disposent d'un téléphone alors c'est un
téléphone qui est spécialement fait pour
travailler en mobilité et donc les
gendarmes à l'avenir pourront faire
l'ensemble des actes de procédure au
domicile des victimes ce qui permet une
meilleure un meilleur service
un dernier mot sur ce bilan qu'est ce
que ça vous a apporté personnellement
dans votre expérience en tant que
gendarme alors déjà la découvert d'un
très beau département les yvelines
ensuite découverte une richesse avec
l'ensemble des gendarmes des 700
gendarmes yvelinois également l'ensemble
des partenaires qui étaient nombreux le
1er juillet dernier et enfin une
découverte j'irai sur soi même puisque
on laisse quand même quelque chose dans
un poste où on a été pendant trois ans
donc voilà un bilan très positif avant
de partir l'actualité c'est c'est les
vacances d'été
vous avez mis en place avant de partir
avant de quitter votre commandement le
plusieurs dispositifs vous avez préparé
ses vacances d'été
l'opération tranquillité vacances et que
vous l'avez dit la brigade territoriale
de contact comment ça se met en place
sur le territoire
alors en fait chaque citoyen qui part en
vacances peut se présenter dans un
commissaire de police ou une gendarmerie
pour déclarer qu'il part et on lui fait
remplir un petit formulaire qui est
rentré dans nos bases de données et il
ya une surveillance qui se met en place
autour de son domicile
donc il voulait se rendre directement
dans dans leur brigade où est tout à
fait dans leur brigade ou leur
commissariat parfois les polices
municipales au siphon ce service l'autre
point c'est les routes un beau coup
double et noir vont prendre dans
quelques jours la route des vacances
quels conseils vous donneriez aux
yvelinois qui se prépare la séance de
conseil
j'irai il fait chaud quand même même si
on est sorti des chaleurs mais pensez à
faire des pauses régulières donc toutes
les heures on s'arrête pour se détendre
et puis quand on est sur un lieu de
vacances ce qui est important également
c'est de ne pas laisser sa voiture
ouverte pour éviter les vols dans les
voitures les choses qu'on rencontre
assez souvent en période estivale et sur
le contrôle des routes du côté des
gendarmes cette fois ci on sait que il
ya plusieurs péages qui peut sur le
territoire des yvelines
il ya le péage de buchelay dans le nord
et le péage de saint-arnoult comment
vous avez mis en place là aussi les
dispositifs parce que je suppose que il
peut y avoir aussi des excès notamment
de vitesse oui tout à fait alors là on
fait surtout des
des missions de prévention 1 c'est à
dire qu'on va être très visible sur les
week-ends de départs afin que les choses
se passent pour le mieux l'avenir pour
vous ce sera la direction générale de la
gendarmerie nationale
alors déjà expliqué à nos
téléspectateurs qu'est ce que c'est la
dggn
alors comme vous le dites la direction
générale de la gendarmerie nationale
elle s'occupe de la stratégie nationale
de la gendarmerie
donc c'est tous les projets nationaux
qui sont traités dans dans ses murs donc
moi je serai en charge de du suivi
justement des grands projets
stratégiques de la gendarmerie notamment
au niveau digital et donc c'est quelque
chose qui est extrêmement intéressant et
j'irai qui va se nourrir de cette
expérience que j'ai eues dans les
yvelines afin de mettre en place des
dispositifs en phase avec le terrain et
qui répondent vraiment aux besoins des
citoyens
c'est la conséquence de ce que vous avez
développé dans les yvelines
oui alors moi j'ai toujours été assez
innovant j'aime bien les
expérimentations donc je pense que ça
sera des qualités qui seront requises
pour ce poste
bon et en plus vous serez juste à côté
vous serez à issy les moulineaux
on voit tout à fait à l'essai à issy les
moulineaux donc j'ai bon espoir de
revenir dans les yvelines régulièrement
et sur notre antenne aussi avec plaisir
pour des sujets nationaux par contre
colonel loïc barras merci beaucoup et
donc votre successeur le colonel sylvain
tortelier prendra officiellement la tête
du groupement des yvelines le 1er août
prochain dans l'actualité hausse ils
protestent contre la réforme des lycées
500 à 600 correcteurs et du baccalauréat
sont en grève en ile de france mouvement
qui touche aussi au moins à trois jurys
du bac s au lycée hoche de versailles
ces professeurs ont prévu de ne pas
transmettre les notes et jusqu'à demain
jeudi au moins les résultats officiels
eux de l'examen elles doivent être
dévoilés ce vendredi l'éducation
nationale a prolongé exceptionnellement
à la période de saisies à des notes
jusqu'à cet après midi trouver un
logement l'une des premières étapes
avant de commencer un cursus pour les
étudiants pour faciliter ce processus
qui s'avère parfois difficile lu vs qu
proposer un forum logement il ya
quelques jours c'était à la maison
martha panne à guyancourt vous voyez ces
images tournées par yves obstine berger
sur place
leurs partenaires du crous à la caf en
passant par yveline information jeunesse
et diverses solutions s'offrent aux
jeunes pour l'hébergement résidence
étudiante logement intergénérationnel ou
encore location de chambres le logement
est un enjeu important pour nous pour se
loger se refait un copain c'est pas
évident mais heureusement que la
communauté d'agglomération universités
ainsi que le crous de versailles ne
mettant en place des dispositifs pour
pouvoir répondre à cette question
l'université à l'issue de ce forum nous
essayons de proposer le maximum de
palettes de logements aux étudiants
le gros avantage de faire ce genre de
forum en fait c'est de pouvoir vraiment
rencontrer directement les personnes
parce que forcément on peut tout faire
en ligne c'est pratique sauf que quand
il y en a des questions qui restent
souvent sans réponse parce qu'après on
appelle on tombe sur des boîtes vocales
enfin c'est pas c'est pas forcément en
top donc là franchement un forum comme
ça on peut discuter directement avec les
personnes c'est largement mieux et si
vous n'étiez pas ce forum logement que
vous êtes toujours à la recherche d'un
hébergement étudiants référez vous au
service logement de l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines et
des offres de propriétaires privés
existent aussi elles sont à retrouver
sur les haies deux plateformes qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran 150 classes
des yvelines ont participé cette année
aux défis technologiques durant toute
l'année scolaire les élèves ont
travaillé sur ce projet scientifique
thème imposé
c'était le jardin la remise des prix
avait lieu lundi soir à la commanderie
d'elancourt le reportage d'aurélie ans
voici l'un des projets qui s'est
distingué pour le défi technologique
cette année dans les yvelines
ce jardin intégrant un système
d'irrigation autonome est l'oeuvre d'une
classe de cm2 de jouars pontchartrain
on a eu plusieurs
essai et voilà en fait on a dessiné les
projets qu'on devait faire au début et
pas j'ai ramené de des plantes y en
avait certains autres aussi qui l'ont
ramené des pentes à planter c'est une
classe qui est qui a accroché à la
problématique qui était soulevée
et puis le centre d'intérêt de fabrique
exposent ensemble ça a réuni toute une
classe un intérêt aussi l'avis de la vie
de classe du groupe
la remise des prix avait lieu à la
commanderie des longs cours chaque cycle
devait suivre un cahier des charges
imposé par l'éducation nationale
objectif pour les élèves réinvestir des
savoirs scientifiques et un gros travail
au niveau des enseignants et des élèves
puisqu'on va être sur une démarche
d'investigation c'est à dire essayer de
se documenter de faire des recherches
pour essayer d'élaborer un projet appuyé
de répondre à la question de départ
parce que c'est une question c'est une
problématique sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines près de 1000 élèves
ont participé à ce projet un défi
technologique qui se veut également
pédagogique on prend des exemples très
concrets pour pour aborder cette cette
façon cet état d'esprit de nos jeunes
que l'on leur transmet avec les profs
éducation nationale donc voilà ça fait
partie c'est ça la pédagogie d'avenir au
total 150 classes des yvelines ont
relevé le défi sur le thème du jardin
cette année mais justement pour ces
jeunes qui ont ou qui vont bientôt
terminer l'année scolaire c'est peut
être une idée de sortie à faire cet été
trois cent soixante sept ans qu'elle se
déroule en forêt de saint germain en
laye elle a fait des loges à a démarré
pour cette semaine c'est jusqu'au 18
août
l événement forains a beau être le plus
ancien de france il propose encore cette
année des nouveautés ambiance avec
patrick jacques de dixmude
c'est sa première alors fait qu'ils
goûtent à tous les manèges sera pas
cette année ce sera l'année prochaine
que ce soit pour une balade en famille
ou des sensations fortes entre amis la
fête des loges à plein de ressources
pour cette 367e les visiteurs peuvent
découvrir plus de 200 animations stands
jeux et bien sûr les traditionnels
manèges
je pense que c'est merveilleux c'était
génial vraiment génial et bien c'est
quoi c'est plus convivial que la foire
du trône qui est très grande a fait
lâcher un peu plus convivial et on
respire mieux si certains sont venus
pour un moment de détente d'autres ont
bien sûr profité de la visite en forêt
de saint germain en laye pour monter
dans les attractions les plus
impressionnantes et le courage n'est pas
à bloc chez tout le monde
les sensations j'ai peur qu'il leur
laisse aller jusque nous entendions
d'ajustement des sensations fortes plus
on aime ça donc on choisit les manèges
les plus ascensionnel c'est la première
et la seule à temps ouais non là c'est
bon ça nous a retourné un petit peu le
coeur mais c'était sympa vous avez
jusqu'au 18 août pour profiter de la
fête des loges plus de deux millions de
visiteurs sont attendus sur place
c'était
m
mais si vous êtes plutôt activités en
intérieur on ne sait jamais je vous
propose d'aller à présent au cinéma
notre petit tour hebdomadaire dans les
salles du territoire fait escale ce soir
aux clayes-sous-bois la programmation de
l'espace philippe noiret au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude cette semaine
dans les salles de l'espace philippe
noiret de la ville de les
clayes-sous-bois nous avons la sortie
nationale des spider man far from home
nous vous conseillons d'aller voir le
dernier avenger engament avant d'aller
voir ce film car il contient des
spoilers important du dernier avengers
peter parker alias spider man souhaite
partir en vacances en europe rejoindre
ses amis et tenter de conquérir le coeur
de la gêne mjp la terre est à nouveau en
danger
à ce moment-là et c6 et le chef du
shield qui sera rappelée à notre super
héros spider man
elle est bien en danger ni sympathique
arctique il se fait donc aidé par un
nouveau super-héros marvel liste bec
leaf incarné par jack ghislaine rôle
afin de sauver le monde et donc la
planète terre une mission l'on retrouve
donc énormément d'action de grands
effets spéciaux et toujours une note
d'humour dans les dialogues ce qui check
ceci sera génial
il vous plaira allez donc le voir dès
mercredi 3 juillet
est-ce que tu va assumer
[Musique]
programmation au cinéma programmation
aussi dans les salles du territoire les
salles de spectacles qui tombe qui ont
toutes terminé on va y arriver si on
tout est terminé ou quasiment leur
saison mais quels sont les affiches de
la saison prochaine un exemple dans ce
journal au théâtre alexandre dumas 7 à
saint germain en laye l'entretien est
menée par mélanie poquet sous la caméra
est de patrick jacques de dixmude une
saison éclectique au théâtre alexandre
dumas de saint-germain-en-laye on vous
accueille pour la saison 2010 9 2020 en
théâtre en musique et en danse et pour
découvrir ce qui vous attend dès la
rentrée nous accueille au sein même du
théâtre sa directrice sophie bauer
bonjour bonjour alors la saison commence
chez vous en octobre avec une pièce qui
a connu un triomphe depuis sa première
en 2010 alors on le précise la
distribution a un peu changé mais
l'effet des textes de matthieu delaporte
et alexandre de la patellière est
toujours présent je parle bien sûr du
prénom exactement grands films grand
grand spectacle franc succès public mais
effectivement bernard murat le metteur
en scène a eu l'audace de remonter ce
spectacle avec florent peyre notamment
dans un des rôles principaux
et c'est vraiment à paris réussis les
comédiens sont bourrés d'énergie
prennent un plaisir immense à être sur
scène et l'effet surprise de ce prénom
reste tout à fait intacte même quand on
connaît très bien la narration pour
revenir le bar sont exactement s'en
lasse pas tout à fait
des mots et de leur portée les choses
dans merde s'appelle fils comme je me
sens maintenant je suis désolé mais je
n'ai pas de cours de près non recevoir
de quelqu'un qui a fait ses enfants
voilà et me retire
[Applaudissements]
alors en théâtre toujours on retrouve
aussi deux visages connus de la sixième
chaîne lionnel astier frédéric bouraly
qui se cherche à trouver de mensonges et
une vérité est là une pente très loin on
part très très loin ne cherchant jamais
à essayer de surprendre un conjoint que
l'on croit connaître par coeur
donc voilà ce couple d'une cinquantaine
d'années va se redécouvrir c'est un
c'est rocambolesque dans l'histoire et
c'est vrai que les deux comédiens sont
fabuleux également mention coup de coeur
pour lionnel astier ont besoin de deux
personnages complètement différent on
l'accusera cabotine r1 pu pêcher alors
il ya des moments drôles dans votre
saison sûr mais il ya aussi des moments
très forts avec une pièce sur la mémoire
une autre sur l'occupation leur
l'occupation et qu'un hommage au style
exactement la mémoire effectivement nous
allons retrouver patrick chesnais dans
un grand rôle avec tu te souviendras de
moi qui aborde le thème de la maladie
d'alzheimer
patrick chesnais incarne un grand
professeur d'université qui peu à peu va
perdre la mémoire il n'oublie cependant
pas l'homme qu'il est et qu'il a été
c'est une pièce extrêmement touchante
dans laquelle il joue avec sa fille
donc on aura également un franc succès
l'occupation à comprendre comme une
occupation mentale puisque romane
bohringer salle en scène interprète une
femme obsessionnellement jalouse de sa
rivale c'est un texte d'annie ernaux on
sait une plume féminine et au scalpel
c'est un langage un peu cru mais rempli
d'autodérision également un très beau
spectacle avec une belle comédienne
alors on a parlé beaucoup de théâtre
mais alexandre dumas 7 aussi de la
musique avec là encore de l'éclectisme
tout à fait c'est vrai qu'on a accentué
la programmation musicale notamment avec
trois concerts qui est notre parcours
concerne les majeurs c'est un nom que
nous avons trouvé pour caractériser de
cet événement ces trois rendez-vous sous
forme de récital avec trois pianistes je
dirais jeune vingtaine d'années mais
déjà connu de par le monde un très grand
les grands ensembles des grands
orchestres des artistes qui ont été
repérés notamment à l'opéra national de
paris qui s'arrêtent chez nous pour
trois dates s'aimer séné par patrick
petit mais ça musical de saint germain
en laye qui nous fait vrai
honneur d'accueillir et de programmer
ces trois artistes à découvrir sous
forme d'un tarif préférentiel également
alexandre quant aux rough notamment ce
sera des nôtres au mois de janvier de la
musique du monde avec un coup de coeur
fatoumata diawara qui une belle
actualité actuellement chanteuse
africaine originaire du mali qui mixtent
les somaliens avec du jazz du blues que
nous programmons avec la clé smac de
saint-germain-en-laye parce que nous
l'aimons découvrir ensemble des pépites
que nous proposons public
nous allons commémorer debussy comme les
années précédentes avec un petit format
concert-lecture mise en scène par didier
magne en début de saison brad octobre
puis avec l'orchestré des siècles avec
lesquels nous accueillons les grands
solistes de l'orchestré au mois de mars
à l'occasion vraiment à nouveau de
l'anniversaire de la mort de debussy
alors ça fait beaucoup de dates on va en
voir encore quelques-unes il ya aussi de
l'humour chez vouera pouvoir rire il ya
caroline vigneaux il ya max berne ou
encore le new un groupe qui revient chez
vous quatre ans plus tard nouveau
spectacle effectivement triomphale il ya
quatre ans chez nous on a eu vraiment
tous les âges dans la salle ils
reviennent pour leur nouveau spectacle
l'humour est toujours aussi dévastateur
en même temps l'école et les musiciens
sont excellents musiciens donc on re
découvre toute la palette de la musique
classique mais comme à chaque fois les
violons deviennent des guitares on joue
au ping pong sur scène en appréciant les
grands compositeurs
on croit vraiment à des contrées alors
les famines sont pas en reste bien sûr
10 et 11 décembre notamment on va
pouvoir rêver que le sable de lorraine
bio rennes c'est vraiment magique ça
serait taxe est c'est tout à fait
magique vous vous dites vraiment le
juste mot puisque leur reine bihorel
invente un dispositif tout particulier
sur une grande plaque de verre elle
installe en fait un simple filet de
table sur lequel elle va dessiner des
images fabuleuses pour raconter des
contes là s'est projeté aussi sur grand
écran et avec très peu en fait elle nous
emmène dans un grand voyage c'est
vraiment à découvrir
la saison dernière vous accueillez roger
sont régis obadia pardon pour une grande
création autour de la reine margot est
ce qu'il ya une autre création qui est
prévue cette année
oui tout à fait c'est vrai que s'il ya
eu un vrai engouement du public un pur
pour ce temps fort une résidence de six
semaines à saint germain ce qui est
exceptionnel et cette année en 2020 plus
tôt nous allons rendre hommage à jean
yvon l'ormeau grand danseur étoile de
l'opéra de paris qui nous a quittés il
ya trois ans maintenant mais qui a été
élève
un élève phare au conservatoire claude
debussy de saint germain grande soirée
hommage parrainé par les danseurs de
l'opéra de paris et des grands
chorégraphes comme il isabelle at elle
notamment ici à leur école de danse
libéral pas exactement qui sera présente
parmi nous donc on retrouvera des
extraits des grandes et grands des
écritures chorégraphiques gisèle roméo
et juliette mais également une petite
création d'un quart d'heure par les
danseurs de l'opéra pour lui rendre
hommage ce sera l'occasion de découvrir
l'univers de la danse et son excellence
aussi puisque vous pourrez interroger
les danseurs sur leur métier fait rêver
on passe maintenant à la question piège
vous programmé une cinquantaine de dates
ou est-ce que parmi elles gagnent un
coup de coeur une oeuvre à ne surtout
pas manquer alors je dirais en théâtre
la mouche
mise en scène par christian hecq
sociétaire de la comédie française
nous l'avions accueilli à quatre ou cinq
ans maintenant avec un spectacle jeune
public 20 milieu sur les mers il a un
univers foisonnant particulier plein
d'inventivité et là vous connaissez le
film de cronenberg des années 80 il va
en donner une mise en scène des
répétitions vont commencer cet été et on
attend vraiment avec impatience le
résultat final puisque c'est voilà cet
homme se transformera en mouche comment
rendre ça au théâtre c'est toute la
question mais je ne doute pas qu'il
trouvera des réponses
incroyable merci de sophie boissard la
saison du thé à des débute le 9 octobre
pour être sûr de ne rien rater
direction le site internet
[Musique]
et pour connaître la programmation de
saison des principales salles de
spectacles du territoire rendez-vous à
cet été sur tv 78è deux émissions
spéciales du 7-8 culture pour refermer
ce journal retour sur un événement
sportif le vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines a accueilli pendant
trois jours la 8e édition du cross site
french trop down un rendez vous qui a
réuni plus de 9000 à personnes dont 500
compétiteurs patrick jacques de dixmude
et michael et demi d'euros des sportifs
ultra musclé un rythme effréné la fièvre
du crossfit a gagné le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
pendant trois jours la structure a
accueilli pour la toute première fois le
crossfit french fredonne la compétition
a attiré près de 9000 personnes dans
l'enceinte mois jongler j'ai fait ce
genre de boulot dans plus de 100 pays
les infrastructures ici sont
exceptionnels la flexibilité de l'équipe
aussi nous permettent de concerts on a
construit un stade à l'extérieur on a un
village partenaires sur la compétition
plusieurs catégories tête au programme
des moins de 18 ans plus de 50 ans au
total 540 participants venus de 47 pays
se sont affrontés à travers une dizaine
d'épreuves qui mêlait à la fois force
endurance précision et vitesse
même ma catégorie eric saade très gros
niveau donc ouais c'est un honneur
d'être ici
c'était vraiment un événement réussi
pour moi c'est le maire événements en
europe qui existent pas il est très haut
très haut je pense quoi que ce soit que
ce soit si haut niveau ça nous pousse
même nous les plus petits pour devenir
plus gros et plus fort donc très très
gros niveau est très intéressant
je pensais pas avoir autant de monde ici
et c'est vraiment bien ça montre que
crossfit a beaucoup d'importance
les meilleurs ont remporté un chèque de
dix mille euros et le droit de
participer au crossfit games
l'équivalent de la coupe du monde de la
discipline
vu le succès rencontré cette année les
organisateurs discutent déjà d'un
éventuel retour au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines
c'est la fin du set 8 journal merci de
l'avoir suivi reportage et édition
complète a consultés sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile
dans un instant au nouveau numéro du 7 8
des baptêmes ce soir les devoirs pendant
les vacances scolaires elle bonne ou
mauvaise idée
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]